[Music]
there's a great line by Lev Manovich
that says that cinema essentially became
a new branch of painting painting in
time think about no other technology
that preceded it for capturing the
numinous for clothing the numinous
unfolded in the dimension the fourth
dimension of time so photography we were
able to take a picture of a moment
ecstatic painting again creating a
portrait a snapshot of an ephemeral
experience whereas cinema became this
branch of painting that unfolds in time
and so consider that notion all of a
sudden we had a technologically mediated
dream space a way to access portal to
the numinous that unfolded in the fourth
dimension so cinema became a kind of
waking dream where we could travel in
space and time where we could travel in
mind this became more than virtual
reality this became a real virtuality
the simulated catharsis the symbolic
allegorical hero's journey we got to
take every time we watched a movie
became real right was literalized in our
psyche you know we became literally soul
surfers when we watch movies and and
like the film Inception says the
director is able to architect what is
essentially a dream space that the
audience can then fill with their
subconscious you know it Linklater goes
even farther he says that um he says
that that human beings knew how to watch
movies because we've been doing it for
hundreds of thousands of years already
in the dream space and so the reason
that it was so natural so intuitive so
innate for us to know exactly how to
watch movies when these
was because we've been doing it every
night forever so what we see with cinema
is that technological advancements met
consciousness in a new art form giving
us access to new luminous realms and
love this notion as I love the
transformative capacity of cinema has a
maximum ultimate expression of inner
subjective explorations transpersonal
spaces spaces of dream spaces of mind
liminal zones it's pushing the limits of
theatrical illusion to see what we can
learn about ourselves
[Music]
you